hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com so i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong and
right now i'm doing youtube videos
because guys i want to show you how
projectors are actually working i know
that a lot of you
have now a new interest for the markets
but you don't know exactly what to look
at who you can trust
and this is the reason why i want to you
know explain to you the different tools
we use the different techniques
and so that you can be able to do it
yourself at home
all right guys so in today's video i
want to talk about the uh us 10 year
yield and show you how it's related
the rest of the market let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so this is the 10-year
yield this is the coveted crisis we can
see that the yield just collapsed you
know just the fed funds
uh were going uh close to zero so the
tenure just followed the move and right
now we're having you know some very
interesting move up on this 10-year
yield
so if i do a bit of technical analysis
here you can see that
we had a downtrend that started in 2019
that was tested so once twice three
times
four time and here it we have a breakout
so what does it mean guys
what is actually this 120 level telling
us
it's very interesting you can compare
this to the s p 500 this is what
actually caused
uh the minus four percent that we had
on the equity market you can see here
that the equity market
actually collapsed so let me go on the
daily time frame
when we have this uh strong move up
happening here
the equity market here lost four percent
at the end of
february the reason behind it is
actually you have some
hedge funds that are specialized in some
momentum trading
of uh rates and the more the rates are
going higher
the more they buy it so the more they
sell bonds and you have other funds
that have uh some systematic strategies
that they're having for a very long time
which is their long equity and they are
long
uh bonds so usually when the rates are
going lower the equity is
going higher but because of these cts
funds that are actually
you know trading this 10-year yield just
buying it you know by selling the the
bond
uh the correlation between the equity
and the bond market and the
the yield market sorry is actually
becoming positive we can
see rates up equity up yes this is what
is happening during bubbles
so what do they do they can see that the
strategy is not working anymore and so
they're selling massively their equity
so this is what created this uh massive
move down that we had uh at the end of
february
so right now what do we have guys we
have this breakout on the 10-year
yield and if i look at uh the very
long-term picture on the weekly time
frame
i can see that uh we having a bearish
trend
uh with a resistance level that is
around
2.8 so this gives me plenty of
room guys for actually this yield to go
higher before maybe the fed is going to
take some more measure to control the
10-year yield which they are not doing
right now so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show i see you guys